now you're a lot bigger than amber
correct
physically
i wouldn't say that
yeah um
the stan i would
you agree with me
on january 17 2013 mr depp
you texted
the following
for the idiot cow
next text will do
i'll smack the ugly [ __ ] around before i
let her in don't worry
and then you close by saying did that
worthless hooker arrive did i read that
right
you did sir mr deb you see the text from
amber that says i'm at a coffee meeting
now you see that i do start there so she
tells you at uh at 12 41 pm i'm at a
coffee meeting now we'll be home soon
and then you respond holy crap
no
meetings no movies why why do you
deviate from our agreement what species
of meeting it just tell me when you get
home i read that right you did put a
coffee meeting
you didn't want her to take the meeting
that she was taking that day correct
um it seems as though we had an
agreement uh
what seems like
we had an agreement to do something
together i'm actually asking asking what
species of mating so this is not
necessarily
angry
text it's just
why do you deviate from our agreement
it's not about her doing
films
how do you think she got aquaman sir
[Music]
and he said i
don't think now is a good time to go
and i thought it's the perfect time
she's not going to be home for two days
and then he showed me a photograph
on his telephone
of uh
objection your honor that's what you're
saying
it's it's a photograph your honor
as being relayed to him by mr bett he he
says he looked at it on his foot on his
phone i'll rule the objection is the
photograph
what was the photograph of mr deb
it was a it was a
it was a photograph of the bed
or bed
um
and on
my side of the bed
um
was human fecal matter
um
so i understood why
it wasn't a good time to go down there
um
my initial response to that
was
i mean i laughed
it was so
outside
it was so bizarre
and so grotesque
that i could only laugh
and
so i did not go down there that day
and then she
she started to
she was telling me about the uh
she brought up the situation of the
her
fecal matter on the bed
and
i
uh
and she just tried to blame it on the
dogs
why didn't you think it could have been
the dogs
the dogs were
their teacup yorkies they weigh about
four pounds each
[Music]
the photograph that i saw
and
i mean
i lived with those dogs for many years
and so did
hilda vargas
my
she's a she's a woman who's been with me
for 30
plus years you know from the very
beginning
and she was the one who photographed it
um
it was clear
she knew the dogs as well as i did
and there was not
none of that did not come from a dog
it just didn't